hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast integrating novel advances in
gene delivery and genome engineering for
therapeutic application presented by dr.
David Schaffer professor of chemical and
biomolecular engineering department of
bioengineering director of the berkeley
stem cell sensor and university of
california berkley i mix a burqa tears
of lab roots and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Schaefer I will now turn the
presentation over to him I'd like really
like to begin by thanking laberd's for
the opportunity to share some hard work
with you today so I'd like to take a
historical perspective and talk about
the nature of healthcare problems in our
country the United States over the past
hundred years where a century ago the
leading causes of death in the US were
tuberculosis and influenza which are
short term acute infectious diseases and
with advances in medicine over the past
hundred years namely antibiotics and
vaccinations and other public health
care measures by and large a number of
these short term infectious disease
problems have been largely addressed
within the country and what this has
done has done has unmasked a large
number of
other indications that are shown on the
slide here so regardless of which
particular tissue you can take a look at
conditions such as Alzheimer's or
Parkinson's or rare disorders such as
Huntington's or lysosomal storage
diseases where often the progression of
these diseases doesn't occur on the
timescale of days or weeks they progress
instead on the timescale of years - in
some cases even decades so this
progressively robbed patients of their
quality of life as well as drives up the
cost of healthcare within the US so
shown here is a percentage of GDP the
total value of goods and services
produced in our country every year that
is spent on healthcare and this
percentage even though that GDP has been
going up on the order of two to three
percent per year the fraction of the
total GDP that is spent on healthcare
has been rising at a faster rate so that
in 2016 which is the most recent year
for which data are available for us from
CMMS we spend 18 percent of our wealth
on healthcare so to be able to address
these problems and improve the quality
of health we need to develop better
therapeutics better drugs and if we take
a look at a very basic biological level
of potential levels or potential places
in which we could intervene to be able
to treat a condition we all know that
information in our body is stored at the
level of DNA that's transcribed into RNA
and then translated into a protein and
each one of these levels within this
hierarchy is potentially a drug target
so the vast majority of pharmaceuticals
that we currently have available in the
market small molecules and monoclonal
antibodies target proteins to be able to
exert their effects small molecules
typically bind to an active site within
an enzyme monoclonal antibody is
typically bind to some soluble or cell
surface extracellular protein and block
or modulate its function so as we move
up one step in this hierarchy we have
RNA and this includes RNA I or antisense
or mRNA being developed by companies
such as Salmonella or Ionis or Moderne
and finally if we move up to the level
of DNA this brings in a number of
technologies that have been related to
primary focus of my entire career that's
going to be the discussion for for
today's talk which include gene therapy
genome editing and cell therapy each one
of these operates at the level of DNA
where gene therapy typically adds more D
to a genome genome editing modifies or
changes the existing DNA and finally
cell therapy is adding entirely new
genomes by adding cell replacement
therapies to regenerate a tissue that's
been under going to generation for
example so what's the advantage of
operating at the level of DNA well if
you take a look at proteins and small
molecules these are typically temporary
residents of the body that have
half-lives on the order of hours two
days whereas DNA sticks around for the
life of a patient
so the potential advantage here is
illustrated by taking a look at the
timescales of some of the conditions
that we described earlier
so from between diagnosis of Parkinson's
and ultimately when somebody passes away
from juda Parkinson's disease typically
that interval is around 16 years
congestive heart failure it's around 10
years age-related macular degeneration
is not a cosmetic for mortality within
patients but typically by the time
patients were elderly are diagnosed with
AMD and when they ultimately pass away
is around 10 years ago so compared to
these timescales we have small molecules
that typically stay in the body on the
order of hours or perhaps a monoclonal
antibody where if we're lucky it's on
the order of several weeks there's
obviously a huge mismatch between these
two time scales and as a result these
treatments are really treatments they're
not cures for the underlying condition
they only partially improve the quality
of life of the patients and they tend to
be quite expensive so I'd like to
contrast that today with gene therapy
and genome editing tools which I'm going
to be describing over the next few
minutes and there are two clinical
trials well what the first one has
actually led to a regulatory approval
within the United States and the second
is a set of clinical trials for
haemophilia B where now we're out almost
ten years and counting from the initial
time in which patients were first dosed
in those early phase clinical trials and
they're continuously enjoying very
robustly the therapeutic benefit of
those treatments so DNA because it has
the potential to stick around for the
life of a patient provides long term
therapeutic benefit that now matches the
time scale of the conditions that
patients are suffering from so just to
take a step back we have a gene therapy
which is defined as the delivery of
genetic material to the cells of an
individual for therapeutic benefit
and uh the key word that has really been
a significant limitation within our
field over the past several decades has
been literally that whether you're
delivering your replacement gene for one
that might be defective within a patient
or whether you're delivering a construct
that encodes some genome editing tool to
modify the DNA within a patient delivery
has been a major barrier where these
constructs you would like to administer
transfer into a patient cells are often
very large chunks of DNA compared to the
size of a cell at least relatively
speaking for a cell they're not
particularly stable inside the body at
least outside of the nucleus and as it
results it's been very difficult over
the past several decades to deliver
enough genetic material to enough cells
within a target tissue to really begin
to modify disease so over the past 10 to
20 years however investigators have been
identifying very promising delivery
vehicles most often based upon viruses
where viruses of course carry DNA inside
of cells from living that's what they do
when they infect a cell and you can
potentially trick that virus since
delivering a therapeutic piece of DNA
rather than delivering its own gene so
in this case for example we have AB no
associated virus or AAV which is really
going to be largely focused the
remainder of my talk which has been
identified in the in clinical
development as a extremely promising
gene delivery vehicle so it has a number
of features associated with it so it's
among the smallest of all viruses on the
order of five kilobases information
inside of its genome it only contains
two genes that are shown here Rep which
encode cementum enzymes that mediate the
replication of that viral DNA and the
second which is cat which has been a
major focus of my entire career so cap
encodes some structural proteins that
self assemble to form this holo soccer
ball that has 20-sided symmetry and once
this soccer ball assembles a copy of the
genome ends up snaking its way through a
pore on the surface of this capsid in
order to load the virus with its payload
and create an infectious virus that
resulting virus for AAV it turns out is
non-pathogenic it's never been
associated with human disease it's a
pretty harmless virus and a number of
natural variants have been identified at
AAP they have differences in the amino
acid composition on the surfaces the
of these peaks emanating from the soccer
ball and this results in different ways
of interacting that virus with host
cells and host tissues it leads to
slightly different delivery properties
or infectious properties for each one of
these viruses so this virus has evolved
over tens of millions of years a number
of ingenious strategies within that
soccer ball to carry the payload from
point of administration until it reaches
the nucleus of a target cell so for
example once that soccer ball reaches
the surface becomes near the surface of
a target cell it binds to a specific
receptor on that cell surface undergoes
and a psychosis or internalization has a
mechanism to escape and zones another
mechanism to undergo nuclear
translocation and then that capsid unco
sand releases the viral genome or viral
DNA to be able to undergo the next steps
of the infection so this can be
converted into a recombinant gene
delivery vehicle by simply taking the
two viral genes rep and cap cutting him
out at the viral genome pasting him on
to a separate piece of DNA which both
liberate space for the insertion of a
gene of interest which then becomes
loaded into the middle of the soccer
ball as well as renders that resulting
virus replication incompetent within a
patient because it no longer has the
viral genes that are necessary for
replication and it simply deposits that
gene of interest in the nucleus of a
target cell so that it can maintain long
term production of a protein or an RNA
therapeutic from that DNA so these
resulting vectors are extremely safe
they've been in thousands of patients
and again just to remind you greater
than 90% of the human population has
already actually been exposed to a V but
it's not a pathogen it's never been
associated with human disease so we're
starting from a very safe starting point
it's these resulting viruses are
somewhat efficient in clinical trials
for muscle liver lung brain and retina
they results in very stable or long-term
expression or maintenance of that DNA
and expression if they repeated proteins
or RNA from that DNA there have been a
number of advances in making these
manufacturable suit clinical scale
although there still needs to be
significant amount of progress there but
as a result of all these properties this
virus has now enjoyed efficacy within
multiple clinical trials some of which
are shown here so for example for
haemophilia B in the upper left hand
corner spinal muscular atrophy in the
lower right and then two diseases or
disorders that affect the retina and
progressively rob people of their vision
a quarter II me and the lower left and
then Leber's congenital amaurosis in the
upper right hand panel so Leber's
congenital amaurosis er LCA 2 was
actually the basis last year of an
application to the FDA to have an
approved product gene therapy to be able
to treat this condition using an AV
vector by SPARC therapeutics and this
became the very very first fda-approved
therapy gene therapy for rare disease so
we have a number of positive results
within clinical trials for a number of
different conditions and so you get the
sense that the field is beginning to
build momentum
however for one reason or another each
one of these conditions for which their
husband's success has been a quote
unquote low-hanging fruit on the tree
for one reason or another these have
been special cases where the natural
versions of these viruses have been just
good enough to be able to get efficacy
and even so investigators have had to
brute-force with delivery use extremely
high dosages or very invasive routes of
administration to place the factor right
next to the cell target inside the body
so in general gene therapy is beginning
to work and genome editing can build
upon that success but the majority of
human disease targets are still beyond
the reach or the capabilities of current
gene delivery technology we quite simply
need better viruses so what are the
current limitations with some of the
natural versions of a ap while I alluded
to one of those which is the fact that
the majority of us have already been
naturally infected accidentally by a V
and we've been as a result immunized
against a ap been vaccinated so we have
high concentrations typically in
antibodies that are waiting to
neutralize a ap whether it's a natural
AV infection or an administration of a
medicine at DNA therapy based upon a ap
even if the virus is able to make it
pass those antibodies and turns out
those antibodies are pretty significant
challenge it's the most common reason
that patients are turned away from a
clinical trial even if the virus does
not have antibodies as a barrier it
often bio distributes to the wrong
tissues inside the body has inefficient
spread when it reaches the surface of
those target tissues as zero capacity
target one cell type versus another
within those tissues and even if it
reaches the surface of a target cell
most cells in the body are not highly
efficiently and infected by a V so we
came into this field around 20 years ago
and began to observe some of these
challenges and hypothesize they arise
from a very simple kind of no-brainer
consideration which is that nature never
evolved viruses for our convenience to
use as medicines so if we want to
optimize these viruses for therapeutic
gene delivery
we need to re-engineer them at the
molecular level to make those soccer
balls better as therapeutic
pharmaceutical gene delivery carriers
rather than being at the mercy of
whatever natural viruses nature happens
to have thrown over the fence ass so
when we began this work we began to
recognize and embrace the idea that
evolution is what created these viruses
in the first place so why not simply
continue that process of evolution but
changed the direction so that we can in
a laboratory setting if all the viruses
towards the properties that we need them
to have to be therapeutic gene delivery
vehicles again rather than being at the
mercy of the natural versions of these
viruses so we developed an approach to
platform technology to be able to do
this which is described in this slide so
the soccer ball is encoded by the cat
gene and so we have the potential to
engineer that cat gene to improve the
properties of that soccer ball to
delivery vehicle so the way that we do
this is that we take these sequences of
these cap chains and I mentioned to you
there are a number of natural versions
of babies perhaps we take not just one
but several different versions of these
captions and we continue the process of
viral evolution to make better versions
for our therapeutic applications so
evolution and all evolution involves two
steps genetic diversification to create
a rich gene pool and then Darwinian
selection to the fittest so we have used
37 different approaches to create 37
individual libraries of the cap gene in
which we've introduced diversity into
that capsid in a variety of different
ways we then take this very very large
pool which in sum total amongst those 37
libraries that we simply pool all
together to create a master library we
have several hundred million variants of
AAV which we think compares quite
favorably to around the half-dozen a
these that are currently used within the
clinic
we then package these AAV genomes into
large numbers of particles so that we
now have a library of particles where
every single variant protein shell or
variant soccer ball contains inside of
it the DNA that encodes that soccer ball
so we can then select this very large
pool for the fist variants that for
example are optimal of being able to
mediate delivery to the liver to the
brain or to the lung or to the skeletal
muscle and we can screen or select them
I'll show you a couple of examples to be
able to isolate the fittest from this
pool and simply spin around this loop
multiple times that we progressively
improve the properties of this virus and
at that the end of that evolutionary
process or perhaps at certain junctures
along the way
we can pop open those particles sequence
the cat gene and gain insights into the
process of evolution as this very large
several hundred million variant library
converges now down just to several lead
variants that have the properties that
we would like them to have so we have
been doing this now for 20 years and
have evolved a number of different
highly optimized targeted viruses to be
able to address the number of those
problems I mentioned to you earlier for
a number of cell and disease targets and
I'm going to give you a couple of
examples today within the retina as well
as in the brain and spinal cord and then
I'll talk about our efforts to translate
to the clinic and finally just show you
a several slides and a new tool that
we've developed recently to be able to
accelerate the process of genetic
diversification and selection so first
the retina so the retina is based upon
that fda-approved product to treat this
blinding disease Leber's congenital
amaurosis is a very important and
promising target for gene therapy so the
structure of the retina is that on the
back surface of our eye we have painted
several layers of neurons so for example
this onl or outer nuclear layer contains
the photoreceptors that sense photons
this information once it activates those
neurons is translated is translated
through several interneuronal layers
until it reaches the retinal ganglion
cells within the ganglion cell layer and
this information is sent through their
axons which comprise the optic nerve
into the brain and for processing of
that visual information so one
particularly important area within the
retinas within the center part of the
eye called the fovea or the macula and
this contains a really high
concentration of a cone
photoreceptors and these are important
for high acuity vision so if you're
reading across a page the reason your
eye moves back and forth is so that you
can keep your phobia focused on a region
where you need the highest visual acuity
unfortunately mutations in over 200
genes can result in the generation of
photoreceptors within the eye in
particular loss of cones is something
that's particularly devastating to
patients because that's leads to loss of
their high acuity or high accuracy
vision so it'd be very advantageous to
deliver a therapeutic chunk of DNA to
the cells in the outer nuclear layer
either the photoreceptors or the
underlying retinal pigment epithelium to
be able to treat these genetic disorders
and furthermore gene therapy could
potentially be harnessed to treat other
complex diseases within the eye such as
macular degeneration so the most
advantageous place to deliver to
administer a therapeutic would be into
the vitreous fluid of the eye so called
interval injection and this is very very
safe and simple as administration it's
actually done several million times a
year within the United States to treat
patients with age-related macular
degeneration with drugs that are
developed by Genentech and Regeneron for
example so this has the advantage that
it's a very simple outpatient procedure
it takes an ophthalmologist around four
seconds to do an interventional
injection in addition once the
therapeutic is within the liquid humor
of the eye it has the potential to come
in circus into contact with the full
surface area of the retina and as a
result in theory protects all cells all
the photoreceptors within the retina
unfortunately a V which is around a
twenty five nanometer particle faces a
number of barriers in reaching those
target cells reaching those
photoreceptors after an injection into
the vitreous so specifically there's
several hundred microns of dense fibrous
tissue which separate that vitreous
fluid from the outer nuclear layer which
contains the the target photoreceptors
and the natural versions of a V can't
penetrate through that dense tissue in
order to reach the target cell and this
is really representative of a number of
problems in gene delivery where it's
hard to get viruses to very difficult to
reach remote locations inside of tissues
or difficult to get viruses to penetrate
surrounded tissue as a result of this
limitation
the clinical trials have been conducted
today including the ones for LCA - which
led to that FDA approval have involved a
subretinal surgery where the needle is
punctured through the retina and fluid
containing the viruses injected
underneath the photoreceptors which
causes a retinal detachment
the fluid forces its way underneath the
photoreceptors which separates the
photoreceptor layer separates the retina
from the underlying tissue and in
patients who are undergoing a retinal
degeneration you might imagine that that
it's insult injury it further damages
the tissue and in addition within this
fundus image which is what an
optometrist sees if they're looking
through the lens at the back of your eye
a sub retinal injection places a blob of
fluid with only a smoke within only a
small fraction or percentage of the
surface area of the retina on the order
of 10 to 15 percent so if the therapy
only reaches the cells that are in
contact with that fluid at that
injection site it really sacrifices on
the order of 85 to 90 percent of the
other cells across the entire retina to
the disease so in that fda approves gene
therapy the majority of the retina
undergoes degeneration only a small
fraction that as a result is rescued so
we ask the question can we engineer AAT
to do this to make the trip from the
vitreous fluid all the way back to the
photoreceptors so because there's no
cell culture model that can really
capture the complexion the complexity of
the retina we began to do this within an
animal model and the way that it works
is that we take our entire pool of
several hundred million AAV variants put
them all into a single syringe inject
them into the vitreous fluid of the eye
wait a couple of days in order for those
variants to reach the target cell the
photoreceptors harvest the
photoreceptors isolate the AAV genomes
the cap genes that made it to that
target cell amplify those we package
them and spin around this loop
readmitting this pool to the to the
animal to reach the photoreceptors round
after round so that we end up with
convergence from on the order of ten to
the seventh or ten to the eighth
variants of a bee down to just several
candidate variants that are now been
heavily selected by evolution for having
the properties that we want them to have
namely the ability to infect a
photoreceptor from the trees so in this
initial work we did it as a proof of
concept within a rodent model a mouse
and we found that
tens of millions 100 million variant
pool converged down to just a small
handful of variants shown in a pie chart
here in the lower left hand side were
actually the dominant variant comprised
around 2/3 to 3/4 of the entire pool so
there's a cartoon events out of the
crystal structure and the cap sub
structure that variant in the lower
right hand corner and you can see that
there was some changes shown in green
into some key loops on the surface of
the virus which changed the way it
interacted with tissues and the cells
and potentially made modifications that
enabled that virus to be able to reach
the target cells so shown here on the
left hand side is a slice of tissue
where the bottom part is the vitreous
fluid the top part is going to be the
photoreceptors and this is an
interventional injection of a b2 which
is the variant that is used within that
fda-approved product so you can see
exactly why they have to do with some
rattle injection because if you
administer a B into the vitreous very
little that reaches the photoreceptors
so if we take the identical dosage of
our engineered variant and administer it
to the eye we can see that we're
lighting up the entire retina on every
single cell layer including importantly
the photoreceptors and furthermore this
delivery is not limited to 10% of the
surface area of the retina because we're
putting it into the vitreous and the
virus can diffuse across the entire
surface area of the retina we're hitting
the entire retina so we began to use
this to be able to treat an animal model
of a human disease this is a blinding
disease called retinas Qisas where loss
of functions or mutations within a
particular gene called retinas season
results in degeneration of the retina
and the formation of these cavities or
species in the eye as shown in this
image this cross-sectional image of an
11 year old boy is progressively going
blind this protein is naturally produced
by photoreceptors and as a result you
need to deliver the gene encoding this
protein to the photoreceptors in order
to repair the condition so shown here is
the animal model this is a wild-type
animal this is a retinas keaston animal
and you can see that it copies our fina
copies the human disease quite well with
the formation of these cavities or
species and if we take them a engineered
virus which is called 7m8 and load it
with an inner and inner gene including
the green fluorescent protein
you can see it doesn't modify or change
the formation of these species but if we
load the 7m8 engineered virus with the
therapeutic DNA encoding rebus Giessen
we can see that there's a structural
rescue of the tissue in preservation or
maintenance of the full thickness of the
retina and finally with an ERG Iraq or
electroretinogram you can see here a
wild-type or natural ERG shown with the
dotted line in the upper panel a retinas
casein animal is shown here with the
green pan or the green profile where
this animal is progressively going
flatline or blind ends dia the middle
one which is the dark color we can see
that we're progressively improving the
capacity of these animals to see or to
exhibit ERG behavior and this
preservation or the degree of it is
maintained throughout the entire life of
the animals shown in the bottom left
where only in the case of the engineered
virus delivering the retina ceasing key
do we have preservation of ERG responses
for many months on end and we see that a
number of negative controls which
include natural versions of a AV
carrying the therapeutic DNA or the
engineered version of a AVR 7m8 carrying
it anarchy and GFP which all overlap
with control untreated Al's know I like
to odd to move on to another tissue
target which is going to be on the brain
and spinal cord and this is another
tissue or condition or tissue where
there a number of conditions which
represent serious unmet medical need
anything from Alzheimer's to Parkinson's
to rare monogenic disorders such as
Huntington's disease or amyotrophic
lateral sclerosis so the problem for
delivery to these tissues is that there
are very large tissues the brain is
large and volume and the spinal cord is
very long and it's very difficult to
treat them like a pin cushion meaning
it's hard to do enough direct injections
into these tissues to be able to expose
the full volume of those tissues to
umpires and this is illustrated by a
recent clinical trial and instituted
past or where to be able to treat a
condition called Sanfilippo P which is
the lysosomal storage disease
investigators actually drilled 8 holes
into the stall of patients and it did 16
injections and this was sufficient to
restore around 14 to 17 percent of
natural levels of the the target
which is an enzyme in this disease and
this was not sufficient to be able to
significantly modify the disease so they
had to go through heroic efforts to be
able to get enough virus since the brain
through a large volume of the brain and
this was still not sufficient to be able
to change a disease progression so a
number of years ago we noticed another
mechanism reserves another mechanism
whereby virus could spread inside the
brain this is called retrograde
transport where neurons of course have a
cell body and then they have an axon a
process so if you deposit the virus are
injected right near the tip of that axon
it can undergo endocytosis or
internalization and retrograde transport
back to the cell body and this provides
a mechanism where you can spread the
virus there were large volume for
example if you have a large number of
neurons which all send their projections
and their axons to just one location by
doing a viral injection at that location
you can get the virus to spread through
a large volume and another example was
that in a subsequent study in this case
Brian Kaspar the lead investigator in
the study did an injection into muscle
of the virus and it was retrograde lis
transported along motor neurons back to
the spinal cord and this was used as a
way to deliver a neuro protective factor
to preserve the viability of motor
neurons within the spinal cord in a
mouse model of amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis so this is extremely promising
is a way to remotely deliver DNA to a
large numbers of cells and get it to
spread and within a target tissue but
the problem was this technology was
licensed by a company that begins to
treat mice and then rats and the
non-human primates with a AVS and found
that the natural abies did not undergo
sufficiently high levels retrograde
transport for this to be practical for
human clinical use and another way
visualizing this problem is that it's
very likely that in its tens of millions
of years of evolutionary history natural
Avs have ever been rewarded
evolutionarily for the capacity to
ruptured retrograde transport within a
neuron AV is a respiratory virus so we
decided to set up our own evolution to
reward retrograde transporters and the
way that this worked is that there's a
location within a deep within the brain
called the pons and there's several
layers in the human of the cortex within
rodent models as well as with the humans
the descend there
directions to the pons so we injected
the entire library within the pons
waited a couple of weeks harvested the
cortex amplified the viral DNA that made
it there we packaged it Riaan ejected
into the ponds and spun around that loop
around a half-dozen times so that again
the hundred million variant plus library
converged down to just a small handful
of candidates and specifically there was
one dominant virus we then took this one
loaded it with a reporter gene
specifically led to the expression of TD
tomato a fluorescent protein injected it
into the pons and you can see here with
a single injection of this virus we're
able to light up the entire cortex so we
wanted to quantify the efficiency of
this process and so this is a cytosol
eclis soluble version of a fluorescent
protein so to quantify we actually used
a new clearly localized GFP so we can
count individual cells
Sallis teri logically and you can see
here this is a b2 natural version of a V
there's an injection in the lower left
hand corner you can see a cluster of
green cells however there's nothing in
the cortex which is a long strip of
tissue in the upper right hand corner
this is an engineered version of a V
that is developed by another lab in the
field ejection it's the pons maybe leads
to a few speckles about cells in the
cortex and this is our engineered
version of a V we're with a single
injection in the pons you can see that
we're spray-painting the cortex with
very large numbers of transduce nuclei
meaning we're getting very efficient
expression so if we quantify this degree
of retrograde transport a v1 through a
benign or very low canine adenovirus or
see a v2 is actually used in
neuroscience as a retrograde Lee
transporting virus to be able to do
mapping of pathways inside the brain
it's not particularly efficient at doing
that and we find that our engineered
version which is called a b2 retro it's
actually 50 to 100 fold more efficient
at undergoing retrograde transport
compared to natural versions of ADA T so
for the remainder of the talk I'd like
to kind of transition into using these
tools as a way to deliver genome editing
capacity in vivo and we use this really
quickly I'm going to show you some
spread of this virus we use this virus
this AV to retro to be able to get very
strong spread of
strikes inside the brain so in this
image we ask the question by choosing
several strategic locations for doing an
injection within the brain can we
actually maximize spread along a number
of different axial pathways yeah
really surely strong spread throughout
the entire brain and so in this case we
used a red and green and a blue
fluorescent protein encoding viral
genome did three injections and you can
see with just three injections he can
light up the majority of the brain so we
then loaded this virus with CRISPR cast
nine construct and specifically we
utilized an animal that expresses now TV
tomato naturally at high levels within
the cortex and then we engineered a
version of a staph aureus sa cast nine
that was armed with the guide RNA that
enabled it to cut near the five prime
ends of TV tomato and as a result
through the introduction of insertions
and deletions during non-homologous end
joining should knock out cheated tomato
expression within the cortex so shown
here in the right hand panel we
quantified the fraction of cells within
the cortex that were transduced or
infected by the virus after injection
into the pons and retrograde transport
of the viral DNA to the cortex we want
to find what fraction of those had TD
tomato knocked out so if we used a
control construct which is the left
purple bar this is a control constructs
that contains a non targeted cassadine
you can see that the majority of the
cells greater than 95 percent are
expressing TD tomato but when we use a
guide RNA that arms the cast nine to be
able to attack the TD tomato gene that's
integrated into the into the DNA of the
genomes of these animals you can see
that we're knocking out 80 to 90
percents of expression of TD tomato
within the cells that were infected so
I'd like to now talk about application
of the delivery technologies to be able
to carry therapeutic payloads
therapeutic genome editing capacity into
cells within the nervous system this of
course could in theory be used using any
engineered virus that we created that is
highly optimized and as two to three
orders of magnitude more efficient at
carrying DNA into any target cell we
might be interested in engineering virus
or this could be used to carry genome
editing capacity into other cells or
tissues in the bomb but right now I'd
like to talk about em a trophic lateral
sclerosis or Lou Gehrig's disease which
involves the loss of motor neurons
within spinal cord brain stem and motor
cortex and leads to within three to five
years of onset paralysis and ultimately
on death within patients
so around ten percent of ALS cases are
familial meaning that the the blame for
this condition can be attributed to
mutations within specific inherited
genes within the Jamis of genomes of
those patients and of the familial cases
twenty percent of those are due to
mutations within a gene called
superoxide dismutase one or sod one and
these are inherited in an autosomal
dominant fashion so that you can't treat
the disease necessarily by adding DNA to
the genome what you really want to do is
to erase the event you want to knock out
a gene and currently unfortunately
there's no effective therapies for ALS
so we engineered versions of Si cast
nine or specifically guide RNAs for si
Cassadine then armed it to be able to
cut the human side one gene and you can
see here that in uh lanes one two and
three we have several that are very
effective guide RNAs that confer an SI
cast nine to a strong nucleus to cut the
human side one locus we then loaded this
si cast nine construct with its guide
RNA into a ap administered into animals
using an engineered version of a AV
animal models of ALS that harbor a
mutant version of the human sod one gene
and you can see here that this disrupted
significantly sod1 expression within
these owls so shown in the left hand
panel this is a control construct in
which cast nine has a control guide RNA
that's directed against a and irrelevant
target within the genome it's not
directed against someone and in yellow
you can see there's very high levels of
expression of sod one within motor
neurons which are shown in red however
when we arm cast nine to be able to
attack the human sub one can see there's
a significant knockdown in yellow
immunity activity and knockdown in sod
one expression and this is accompanied
by the the observation of insertions and
deletions at the sod one locus
indicating
Cass nine to cut that locust
non-homologous end joining incorrectly
repaired the locust so that ended up
knocking the sod one out of its reading
frame and a bladed expression of this
this disease-causing allele of Sanwa
I'll finally mention as well that so the
version of av that we used is actually
more targeted towards motor neurons it
is known that expression of the mutant
sod one within other cells in the spinal
cord specifically within astrocytes and
oligodendrocyte precursor cells also
contributes to pathogenesis or the
pathology of this condition but we
wanted to see initially using this
proof-of-concept virus that's more
targeted chose motor neurons if we can
see some extension of lifespan within
these animals and then perhaps we can
tackle the astrocyte and oligodendrocyte
precursor problems in next-generation
therapies so we see here in the the
upper left-hand panels a and B that
there's a significant delay in the onset
of paralysis within these animals that
are treated with the Cassadine directive
against Assad one gene in the upper
right hand side there's a significant
extension in the survival of these
animals so that we delay disease onset
by around 34% and extent and survival by
25% so we're now using improved versions
of the AAV that target delivery not just
to the motor neurons but also towards
glia towards astrocytes and the ligand
end type precursor cells and it's our
hope that these these new and improved
versions of the virus next generation
next next generation versions are going
to be able to to knock out this gene
within other cells that contribute to
disease progression resulting in even
further extensions in lifespan so over
the the next 10 minutes I'd like to talk
about two final steps the first of these
is our efforts to translate into the
clinic so around four years ago also by
way about disclosure or financial
interest since I'm a co-founder of this
company we spun a company out of
Berkeley called 4d molecular
therapeutics and 4-d has been developing
next-generation AVS for a number of
different targets which I'll talk about
a second and we've been progressing
these in clinic both internally within
our own programs as well as the third
partnership with companies like bro
speiser and Astra Zeneca
so evolution or
nature teaches you that within evolution
you get what you select for and I showed
you a couple of examples in which we did
the selection in which we did the
evolution within a Ronit model so as
I'll show you in a second
human beings or primates aren't rodents
and as a result a factor that's
optimized for use within a rodent may
not be yet optimal through human
clinical translation so within 40 we've
been doing the evolution for a number of
different tissues and we've been doing
it within non-human primate models and
human organa typical cultures with the
idea that these are the system's the
preclinical systems that are as close to
humans as is possible so we want to do
the evolution and do the selections
within a setting that we believe is
going to make the resulting viral
technologies directly translatable into
the clinic so we've been doing it and
have a number of natural sorry number of
engineered variants of AAV with
integrity issues including the retina
central nervous system lung liver heart
muscle as well as other targets and
today I want to want to talk about the
retina so why might a rodent vector not
be optimized for use within a larger
mammal and specifically a primate so
first of all there are differences in
the anatomy this is a drawn to relative
scale where the mouse is pretty tiny
compared to the human eye there's on the
order of a hundred microliters of
vitreous fluid within the mouse eye we
have around 4,000 microliters vitreous
fluid in the human eye so there's a
difference in scale and in addition
there's a difference in the anatomy of
the retina where I described to you
earlier that we have this region called
the phobia with high concentrations of
cone photoreceptors and mice don't even
have a phobia so if you want to study a
cone degenerative disorder such as
macular degeneration it's difficult to
do that within a mouse and furthermore
there's a barrier within the tissue that
lies between the vitreous fluid and the
retina this is called the inner limiting
membrane or ilm and this is a barrier to
AV delivery into the retina and this
barrier this eylem is quite simply
thicker within humans and monkeys so we
began to use this
Rhona Navy just to test whether or not
it can work within non-human primate
retina and shown here in the lower right
hand corner so these are natural
versions of a V with a non-human primate
right now they're not
this is the engineered version due to
limitations of time it won't describe
for you why we have this particular
pattern that you can see the majority of
the surface area of the retina is not
protected with this rod or anything so
we re performed the directed evolution
from scratch within a non-human primate
and created a highly optimized version
of AV that should now work with an N HP
and due to the similarity in the
non-human primate retina to that in the
human retina we believe that this is
going to be translatable in the clinic
so to show you our results from this
these are images for images from
non-human primates from an in life study
in which we loaded this optimized soccer
ball this optimized AAV with DNA
encoding the green fluorescent protein
and you can see her at 6 months of age
this is light lit up the retina of these
animals we've quite literally done
thousands and thousands of tissue
sections and stains and examines and
quantified the expression and we see
very high levels of bunching expression
within photoreceptors as well as the
retinal pigment epithelium within these
animals so our initial target is going
to be a blinding disease called corn
arabia and this is due to mutations
within the rf1 gene which encodes a
protein that's important for vesicular
trafficking and for reasons that are not
fully understood compromises the rattle
pigment epithelium within the eye which
in turn leads to death of photoreceptors
and progressive blindness within these
patients so we'll be initiating a human
clinical trial to treat Cordura mia very
early in quarter one next year so I'd
like to close with describing work that
we've done to create kind of a and
next-generation technology to accelerate
the process of evolution of viruses or
in principle any gene and this is again
based upon CRISPR caste 9 which we keep
finding as a terrific tool within the
toolbox to create a number of different
downstream technologies and this is a
work that was published about a month
ago or so so I'm going to describe for
you the molecule and talk about the
application so imagine you have a
version of caste 9 which in which one of
the two nucleus sites has been mutated
so it functions as a nikkei's that only
introduces constants to one strand of
the DNA and we take this nikkei
of caste 9 infuse it to a DNA polymerase
and this DNA polymerase can have some
properties of interest which I'll
describe in a second so upon
introduction of this into the cell along
with a guide RNA it leads to that caste
9 getting recruited to the locus that's
specified by that guide the Cassadine
Nicks the DNA this and this uh version
of this molecule which we call Evolver
then dissociates from that Nick flips
around so the DNA polymerase binds to
that Nick and we choose DNA polymerases
that are actually Nick translating DNA
polymerase and this will end up
displacing one strand of DNA and laying
down a new track of nucleotides and we
can choose this polymerase and then
finally this dissociates at some random
time from the DNA and that flap that's
been displaced ends up getting cut off
and then as a result you've replaced
that original DNA with a new strategy so
the the reason that this is of interest
is that you can introduce into that DNA
polymerase because it's a very modular
system any number of properties we can
change the process can change the
fidelity of that polymerase where for
example we can use an error-prone DNA
polymerase where you can introduce at
some defined rate mutations into that
strand that target strand of DNA in
addition you can change the MIS
incorporation biases specifically so
that certain mutations might be more or
less likely you know H a to T might be
more likely than a T to a or G to C or
perhaps you want even probability of
mutations from any base to any base and
finally you can change the process Civet
e which ends up changing the number of
nucleotides or the window over which
mutagenesis is introduced into a target
locus in the genome
so we've I use this system and examined
it using a number of different
approaches including next-generation
sequencing you can see here on the
x-axis this is a distance from the
target site from the nick and on the
y-axis is the error rate or the rate of
mutagenesis at that locus and you can
see that for this particular polymerase
we end up with mutagenesis stretching on
the order of 50 nucleotides we've seen
it as long as 250 depending upon the
process tivity of the polymerase we use
and we end up with the substitution
frequency on the order of 0.1 to add to
1% so very
hi mutagenesis rate and this is
initially done within bacteria we've
also gotten it to work within mammalian
cells and this is also compared to any
number of negative controls which
include a no mutagenesis if you use an
off target guide RNA no mutagenesis if
you use the on target guide RNA but
using nicking cast 9 that doesn't
contain the DNA polymerase fuse to it
and in some totally mutation rate is
around 8 million fold higher than
wild-type cells at that same locus
that's targeted by Babur
so we've now been using this to evolve
DNA inside of cells and this can be done
in situations where you introduce
exhaustion as DNA into a cell you know
let's say some target proteins such as a
a blue fluorescent protein that you'd
like to evolve into a green fluorescent
protein just as a proof of concept
problem so we've seen that if we target
Evolver to this GFP we end up with
mutagenesis and recovery of gfp we're
switching from a blue fluorescence to
green fluorescence and you can sort that
out using facts we've also had done this
evolution on endogenous loss I in the
genome where in this case we're mutating
a ribosomal protein to end up conferring
resistance to an antibiotic antibiotic
spec 10 of myosin inside of cells you
can see that we end up with acquisition
of antibiotic resistance as a result of
evolving this target at rates that are
multiple orders of magnitude four to
five orders of magnitude higher than
spontaneous generation of antibiotic
resistance and it's a final Pisa it
turns out you can also do this take
advantage of the multiplexing of CRISPR
caste 9 and introduced to guide RNAs one
targeted to one ribosomal gene the 30s
ribosomal protein S 5 which is a target
of the antibiotics pectin Meissen and a
second targeted against 30s ribosomal
protein s 3 which is a target of
streptomycin and only when you have both
of these guides present and as a result
confer upon those cells the capacity to
evolve resistance to both those
antibiotics only in the presence of both
of those guides you end up with
antibiotic resistant bacteria so we're
currently translating this technology
into mammalian cells to evolve things
that might be of interest such as gene
delivery
so I'd like to close with a full a few
bullet points first as gene therapy is
working there now a number of absolutely
bona fide clinical successes and this
has been enabled by and large with viral
gene delivery vehicles but of course
nature never designed or evolved or
optimized these viruses to serve as
human medicines
fortunately technologies such as
directed evolution can be brought to the
rescue to be able to create highly
optimized efficient targeted Vernor
versions of these AAA B's in other words
designer viruses that cannot mediate
delivery to any seller tissue target and
body and we've used this approach to
fundamentally reprogram the properties
of these viruses to increase their
efficiency target delivery and work I
didn't talk about today I'm enhance the
capacity to obey the immune system we're
currently translating this into human
clinical trials as well as working on
next-generation tools such as Evolver to
be able to in principle evolve any
target DNA inside of a cell including
for example a capsid gene so i'd like to
close by acknowledging the people who
actually did this work the work in the
mouse retina was done by leah burned in
east car and tim day and collaboration
with John Flannery on the work on
retrograde transport was the product of
a Tom guy by mule Wang in collaboration
with investigators from janelia farm the
non-human primate retinal variant was a
engineer there developed as I mentioned
at 14 molecular therapeutics with major
contributions from our CEO David Kern
who's also my co-founder our director of
discovery us Melissa Connor Minh SVP of
clinical and translational research
Peter Francis as well as other important
contributors and finally the work on a
polymer was the product of shaked
Halperin in collaboration with John
duper at UC Berkeley so thanks so much
for your time and I'd be happy to
address any questions thank you dr.
Schaefer for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
and
click the send button our speaker will
follow up with your questions via email
let's get started our first question is
what other tissues have you engineered
AAV for so I showed one slide which and
very quickly shows some of the target
tissues that we've developed
technologies for delivery highly
optimized vectors for within non-human
primates and this has worked on it at 4d
so in principle this is a broad
technology platform where if you could
design a selection such as the ability
to reach any target cell with the body
you can use this as a way to evolve an
AV that's optimized for being able to
reach that target cell we've
specifically implement implemented it in
the retina which has showed you data for
within the brain and spinal cord for
liver skeletal muscle heart muscle lung
joints as well as a couple of other
tissues and the lead program that we're
currently developing for the clinic is
within the retina but we anticipate also
being able to take in a virus highly
optimized for a skeletal muscle and for
cardiac muscle as the next candidate
sought to be able to proceed into human
clinical development and how have you
addressed the problems of neutralizing
antibodies against aap yeah I mentioned
this issue that the majority of us have
just been accidentally infected with
natural versions of AAV and as a result
vaccinated or immunized against those
natural abs and we have high
concentrations of antibodies directed
against those natural ATP's floating
around in our blood streams as well as
in other bodily tissues so if delivering
a V to a given tissue requires it to be
administered into some bodily fluid that
has antibodies in that if you're using a
natural version of a a V it just means
that a fraction of the population it's
not going to be a candidate for the
therapy and that could be anywhere in
the literature from 40 to as much as 90%
of the human population is simply not
going to benefit from a product this
developed from some of these natural
versions of ATP so we did evolution
again and took her entire very large
pool and evolved this pool for the
capacity to evade pre-existing
antibodies that are common within the
human population so specific
we took the pooled IgG the pulled an
antibody fraction from around a thousand
donors a product college should be Miss
immunoglobulin which as a result has
lots of antibodies direct against a
because the majority of those donors
were naturally infected with a V so we
took this mixed it together with the
library administered it to cells the
virus that was not bound or tightening
neutralized by these antibodies the
virus is able to infect those cells we
rewarded that virus and provided it with
the opportunity to replicate his genome
to increase its frequency within the
gene pool and then took it reexpose due
to antibodies and spun around that loop
so that we ended up evolving now
variants of a e that are not neutralized
to nearly as great an extent of compared
to natural versions of AP so we can then
take these and kind of view them as lead
compounds and further genetically
diversified them and engineer them for
now the capacity to reach a target cell
in the bodies that we end up with the
best of both worlds a variant which is
not going to be neutralized by the
majority of pre-existing antibodies and
then does have the delivery properties
the target ability and the efficiency we
wanted to have to be able to reach each
a mutation
all right and it looks like we have time
for one more question
how could you address the problem that
AAV would provide long term expression
of cast night when likely what you want
is transient activity sure yes so I some
time talking today about gene therapy is
a way to augment the genome to add DNA
to cells and this is relevant in
situations where somebody has some loss
of a function or Lassa of a change in a
mutation that we simply need to replace
replace that DNA in that case you want
that DNA stick around from the very long
periods of time for the lack of the
patient in the case of editing DNA or
editing a gene within the genome by
delivering a genome editing capabilities
such as CRISPR cast 9 you really don't
want it to be around for long periods of
time you just want it to be there
transiently
you wanted to do this job on the genome
and then go away because if you leave
that cast 9 around for long periods of
time eventually you can start possibly
hitting locations in the genome off
target locations that can cause toxicity
than that cell and certainly you know
Cassadine is a bacterial protein
eventually the immune system is going to
notice that a given cell inside the body
is expressing in this bacterial protein
and you might start demanding and
mounting an immune response against that
therapeutically treat itself so you
really want that that cast 9 to be there
quickly and then go away so we and
others have been developing negative
feedback systems where you can take the
target site for the cast 9 which is
present within a target gene in the
genome and take a little copies of it
and also stick it inside the AV genome
so once cast 9 is expressed it hits the
its target site within the genome but
also loops around or boomerangs back and
cuts the viral DNA that encodes the cast
9 and as a result eliminates itself so
this negative feedback loop or this
suicide kind of system provides a pulse
of cast 9 activity long enough for it to
be able to do his job in the genome but
then it goes away well I would like to
once again thank dr. Schaefer for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2019 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye